mon meilleur souvenir au tpn pc lorsque
j'ai eu ma plus de partis à la fin de la
dernière saison je me suis retrouvé avec
une cinquantaine de films dans la
piscine
au delà de la blague bénin pompe je vais
quand même à passer un bon moment entre
un des jerrycans maxellende écope moins
bons souvenirs
c'est lorsqu'on devait se mettre de
l'eau croupie qui sautait le poisson
coudes sous la tête on devait se retirer
l'espoir de mikado et répondre à des
bonnes questions nous a su en afin
d'assurer la santé la vie sardines
[Applaudissements]
je voulais
c'est une réalité qui marque ou à chaque
fois si christian clavier
[Applaudissements]
il est une manière de parler d'années de
traque menée l'histoire parfois de
tacler toujours avec le sourire cauche
balayage jeudi à dire avant pourquoi ces
belgique et le hashtag ya un balayage
qui est très belle qualité année ça va
être conseiller ou de rebond je parle
pas de notre ami là où c'est désastreux
mais c'est très agréable de la voir en
réalité